hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're gonna have probably one of
the most intense in literally series
changing battles from throughout the
dopa series that is chainsaw man like
the pure heart that this part of the
anime will get when it's finally
animated is going to probably break
Twitter in a similar way to a few of
those other Godly arcs like Shibuya from
Jujutsu Kaizen or the infinity Castle
Arc from Demon Slayer will do also when
they get their time to shine it's just
the perfect amalgamation of everything
that is tatsuki Fujimoto the dude is
complete genius at seemingly everything
he does and of course it applies here to
this God tier battle as well where our
boy dingy finally takes his revenge
against the literal Tyrant that is Mummy
makima also I just want to say if you
guys like have noticed a few of my vids
including the full vid going over the
chainsaw man story have been like age
restricted now which looking back at a
few moments that happen throughout the
series kind of makes sense but like even
still as you could all imagine it pretty
badly sucks as it was just four months
of work instantly unsuggested to any new
people that was you know like doing well
on my channel hence why I've got to say
this to YouTube right now this battle
here between people drawn on some paper
right now and the Shonen genre does get
pretty wild at some point so if you feel
as if this content may affect you
negatively or make you uncomfortable
then please feel free to check on
something else anyways anyways I hope
that clears everything up and I hope you
all thoroughly enjoy this as technically
this is a re-upload now but I just
wanted to get something out and quickly
let you guys all know that this has
happened but this is seriously my
favorite fight from throughout the
series so far like I just wrapped up the
first part of the series so beautifully
so obviously massive spoilers for anyone
who is an anime only for real just
before we start off all you guys need to
know is that Genji has probably had the
worst day of his life so far like far
worse than anything you would physically
want to be a witness to yourselves like
you guys will see what I mean soon but
the reason we find him how he is on the
couch is dude ends up doing the dumbest
thing he could have possibly imagined
and gives his will to makima the control
devil now flashing forward to the next
morning everything seems normal as Mucky
mccamley eats breakfast and dingy lies
motionless on her couch she then gets
dressed and guides stingy outside into
the car door there a number of demons
many of whom are dingy's deceased allies
kneel in front of them makima explains
that they were all followers of the
Chainsaw devil whom put their lives on
their line to protect it waiting for the
day of Resurrection as she says this the
building is suddenly breached by devil
Hunter group named the anti-makima squad
led by the old lovable fart keshibe
makima is gunned down and killed as a
number of devil Hunters slip their
throats in order to suddenly summon the
hell devil who they asked to kill makima
and banish her to Hell however hearing
this makima commands dingy to save her
which causes his intestines to burst out
of his chest and throttle him as the
hunters slowly die outside the building
the hell devil emerges now when a
flaming centaur-like form dingy standing
Atop The corpses of the anti-makima
squad pulls his cord and transforms into
the chainsaw devil in an instant he
leaps outside slicing the hell devil
into many cling-cut pieces of Hell
Sashimi as the the blow and guts rained
down he stands tall and a darker more
muscular form with multiple arms and
Blades spawning from him I honestly I
freaking love this berserk level body
armor that he's got on right now it
looks so freaking badass Fujimoto is
actually a beast when it comes to
drawing this kind of like dirty stuff if
you know what I mean that's just how I
feel right now it's so dirty and grimy
it's a clean dingy stands above the
decapitated hell devil as one of the
devil Hunters gives blood to revive it
as he does a door opens above them and
the hell Devil's Hand emerges crushing
dingy like a bug transporting him to
Hell from a nearby building makima
watches commenting on the outcome to
kashibe who now has a gun pointed at her
head as she talks the chainsaw devil
tears through various devils in hell she
explains that within hell the chainsaw
man is known as the hero of hell when it
hears a cry for help they change the
devil moves in eviscerating every devil
it faces Friend or Foe mahimadin
explains the ultimate power of the
Chainsaw devil any devil consumed by it
has he names erased from existence faced
against such an Unstoppable opponent all
other Devils either despise fear or
worship the chainsaw devil so this x
actually goes explain I guess why Bane
was such a fanboy as he literally
worshiped the chainsaw devil and I love
you babe rest in peace Brother anyway
Kiss You by expresses doubt that such a
power could even exist however makima
retort by asking him what he knows of
the Holocaust it has been revealed that
kashiba alongside Humanity at large have
no knowledge of Nazism good old Japan
always bringing up the 40s like it's
just yesterday mahima continues
explaining that almost every major
crisis faced by Humanity will all erased
from existence by the chainsaw devil she
goes on to explain that even Universal
constants such as Humanity's Sixth Sense
and the four possible conclusions other
than death which honestly I have no idea
what that is someone who's like into
that culture or something let me know
down in the comment section below at the
end of life were also erased makima
elaborates explaining that she cannot
even remember these things though she
remembers the fights between their
devils and the chainsaw devil kashibe
asks makima's intentions with the devil
to which she reveals the true nature of
her own ability to control any being
that she believes is lesser than herself
therefore if she were able to defeat the
chainsaw devil in combat she would be
able to control it and use its powers to
create a World Without Pain war or death
kashiba asks what she would do if she
lost to which she replies that she is a
fan of the Chainsaw devil and it would
be a happy honorable end turning back to
the window makima notes stingy's return
as the door to Hell reopens and the
chainsaw devil emerges showered in blood
kashibe continues to stand off of makima
as he stares her down she warns him to
stand back as she turns to prepare to
face dingy in an instant denji bursts
through the wall and slices pieces
before turning and looking to kashibe
suddenly dingy hears someone somewhere
say the words save me and immediately
leaves
kabini quietly mutters the words save me
the staff suddenly turned to see dingy
looming over them greeting kabini with a
VAR the customer attempts to flee but is
instantly decapitated by dinghy dingy
looks at the Restaurant's menu and
remembers an earlier request to pachita
to try hamburgers sitting at a nearby
table he attempts to order a hamburger
speaking through a series of Chainsaw
ribs the restaurant's mascot is
decapitated as he attempts to contact
the devil Hunters suddenly deciphering
dingy's ribs kabini and the other
employees begin to prepare his order as
they sing and dance with panic on their
faces dingy musa's arms shuffling in
time with their dancing cabini is
ordered to deliver the food to his table
however as she does she trips and Spills
the food all over him looking up at the
annoyed dingy kabini asks for another
hamburger as the employees repeat their
dance now with tears streaming down
their faces kabini's boss begins to
shout at her blaming her for their eyes
before he is too decapitated ascabini
again attempts to deliver the order she
trips and falls spilling the food
identically to the first time as She
lays on the floor terrified she begins
screaming her disbelieving co-workers
begin to accuse dinghy of playing an
elaborate televised prank instantly
though he is decapitated as kabini
begins to pick up the ingredients off
the floor and reconstruct the burger
dingy takes a bite before grimacing with
this approval just gotta quickly cut
myself off really quickly here guys I
could have messed up this next part
where the two end up going on this
little like kind of Scenic date together
but pretty much I was meant to say dingy
kind of like phrases and gets stuck
there for the moment pondering on an
idea of how he always wanted to take a
girl on a date I messed up the wording
so bad that I didn't even want to like
re-include it in this area right here I
wanted to just give some context around
it anyway anyway he grabs cabini and
carries her outside then stopping in an
ice cream van dingy shreds it to Pieces
before acquiring a pair of ice creams
for the two of them kabini continues to
SOB crying out that the ice cream
doesn't taste of anything a devil Hunter
then appears and threatens dingy but is
instantly eviscerated as dingy turns
cabini towards a Dance Dance Revolution
machine and orders her to dance after
commenting that she has no money dingy
Dean shreds an ATM and kabini begins to
play out of fear as she continues
dancing dingy actually leaves he then
arrives on top of a rooftop and
surveying his surroundings notices
makima is nearby she comments on him
noticing her as she commands her allies
to emerge suddenly dingy stands
surrounded by seven devil Hunters all
commenting on their love for markima and
desire to date her as the first four
wager a date with machima for killing
dingy the other three are revealed to be
Katana man reset and Quan XI they all
each pledge the allegiance to makima
with the katana man commenting that she
has saved their lives over and over
again as makima agrees to the bit a date
in return for killing dingy which is you
know like a complete role reversal of
what was going on with dingy earlier on
so I absolutely love that I think it's
quite cool Quirk him or not as makima
stands amongst her group of human devil
hybrids she elaborates on their true
nature they are not humans Devils or
fiends but another type of creature that
was erased by the chainsaw Devil's
Powers yet still somehow continues to
exist she explains that whilst fighting
them in Hell the chainsaw devil
disappeared and appeared on Earth as
pochita and they have been searching for
him since as dingy yawns Mucky mcmah
commands her agents to attack each agent
pulls out their weapon transforming
themselves into the hybrid forms and
lunging at dingy as each makes contact
with him they are blown back by the
force of him leaping forward crashing
through skyscrapers while slicing
through Quan XI and the broadsword
hybrid as they land in an apartment
complex dingy kneels over quanji's
tattered body clutching these seeded
heads behind him the katana man appears
attempting to slice through dingy how
however he is unsuccessful as it is
shown Genji was able to decapitate him
without taking any damage himself makima
looks on calmly exclaiming that the
conflict appears unwinnable standing on
the floor below dingy the flamethrower
hybrid flies into the ceiling causing a
massive explosion to burst through the
building as dingy leaps backwards to the
safety onto another building the whip
hybrid appears and slashes into him who
attacks him to have little impact
however as Reza blasts through the
building and grabs dingy carrying him up
into the sky flipping mid-year deanji
decapitates Rize before he is impaled by
spear thrown by the spear hybrid stunned
and mid-ear makima takes the momentary
days to blastinji repeatedly pointing at
him and stating bang as each hit
launches him further and further into
the sky as dingy is pushed out of the
atmosphere and into space makima
comments wondering how long he could
hold his breath reaching inside of
himself though dingy rips out his own
heart and flings it towards the ground
as the heart begins to burn up upon
re-entry into the atmosphere denji's
body begins to reform around it until it
is fully formed still forming dingy
launches his chains across the city
grappling onto makima the whip
flamethrower and spear hybrids then
hoisting them up into the ear they each
Express a moment of shock before they
are too torn apart by dingey's chainsaws
flashing over to cabani whose Dance
Dance Revolution is coming to an end she
stands tired and sweating Atop The
Machine before exclaiming that she
happily got a perfect score her here
turns to the side as she looks over
terrified at chainsaw man who's now
sitting Atop The step across from kabini
cabini stands confused asking to the ear
why she was dancing as makima answers
from above her prompting kabani and
Chainsaw man to look up at her sitting
on the roof above makima goes on to
state that in total she has been killed
26 times by chainsaw man and yet she
questioned why it was that he continued
to refuse to eat her the corpse of the
devil Hunter whom the chainsaw man had
killed prior begins to move being pulled
up to makima as a chain from her body
attaches itself to him and joins makima
floating above several dozen other
chained men kabini starts to show denial
stating twice that she had nothing to do
with the current situation before makima
cuts her off saying that she did indeed
have a major role in the current events
currently unfolding and that the fear of
Chainsaw man had grown weaker this
prompts kabini to look over at chainsaw
man as blood begins to leak from his
body like a mistakes that she liked
humans the same as they like dogs in the
sense that to her they were loyal easily
manageable smart yet stupid and they all
loved her a television show and the
window of a city shot begins
broadcasting the news stating that
chainsaw man had just defeated the
gandival he goes on to state that the
news are the gun Devil's defeat was
being met with a praise and shock across
the entire Globe the broadcaster
continues praising dingy's ability to
get up over and over again despite his
many injuries it then switches to a
woman who's stating that the chainsaw
man was a hero and a man who explains
how dingy had fought the doll Devil's
Army and thanks him for allowing to
escape a woman yells into a mic that she
had seen him riding a shark through the
streets as he fought the typhoon devil a
woman exclaims that he had saved her on
a train a man states that dingy had
protected him from the bat devil and
finally another woman says that he had
rescued her at a rest stop as people are
out on the street celebrating chainsaw
man chanting his name the broadcaster
tells Watchers to go outside and see
what's happening for themselves and that
everyone should join together to cheer
him on even more which is obviously
hella dope for a boy but at the same
damn time dude's getting mad debuffed
right now if you understand what's going
on because with him more and more blood
is shown pulling around him marking
mistakes that the humans cheering him on
were eating away at him and contrasting
the power given to him by all the Devils
who feared him a chained Angel then
appears floating above markima as she
uses his power stay team usage 1000
Years summoning a black red spear as
makima asks if kabini has enough
strength to avoid her coming attack
believing that dingy would attempt to
save her a black circle appears in the
ear in front of makima while three large
humanoid figures appearing in the ear
around the groin Circle at equal
distances the faces of cabani and
Chainsaw man are shown bathed in light
as makima launches the spear at kabini
chainsaw man moves in front of her
pushing her away as the spear passes
through his torso his blood is shown
gushing out of his body as he collapses
face first onto the ground Maki massage
as the crowd continues to cheer for our
ever weakening chainsaw man skipping
away power is shown sleeping on a Miss
of blood and organs complaining as
pochita nudges her with its poor she
opens her eyes and turns her head
towards pachito who tells her to wake up
power initially confused quickly makes
the connection that he was pachita
Vegeta Smiles at her realization before
telling her that he wanted her to save
dingy he tells her that she truly wasn't
dead as she was currently the blood that
dingy had drunk from her before and that
if nothing was done she would soon
disappear Vegeta asks for her to eat
some of him and revive as a full-fledged
devil to watch our freaking girl like
holy [__] I couldn't live without power
being around any longer happily obliges
as dingy as her best friend back in
reality makima moves down onto the
ground with around a dozen members of
Public Safety lined up behind her
chainsaw man begins to get up on his
hands and knees then as he points his
head forwards power suddenly jigs from
his mouth in the form of The Blood Vein
power laughs as she points towards
marking which causes blood weapons to
suddenly push out from within the bodies
of her and all of the public safety
members power yells that she is the
strongest as a bloodied makima uses
Angel's ability to create a sword worth
of a hundred years power then uses a
move she calls thousand Terra blood rain
showering makima with several dozen
blood weapons as they shoot down from
above she gloats and spouts nonsense as
makima is continually impaled like that
she herself was the first president as
the barrage of weapon stops makima calls
on the zombie devil which appears behind
her and turns the deceased members of
the public safety into zombies these
zombies Rush power grabbing onto her and
biting her she screams out in pain as
makima shoots off your arm while they
finger gun makima asks a bleeding power
how she was still alive with power
refusing to answer as she lunges back
grabbing chainsaw man and proclaiming
him as her own makima asks for power to
give her chainsaw man under the threat
of death stating that you let power be
who Peter in if she gave him over
stupidly power fumbles the bag moving
behind chainsaw man and lifting him up
before stating that she had in fact
captured him but cheetah is showing in a
State of Shock and confused as power
happily States the glory was all hers
while power stands there gripping dingy
makima asks for power to give her a
change for man and her head power looks
on her time with dingy thinking back on
when they first met when he first saved
her from the bat devil when they bathed
together and when they gave Aki a meal
they'd cook together Our Queen though
defies that hoe as blood weapons shoot
out of markima forcing her weak ass to
her knees power runs off with dingy
screaming and asking why she was
disobeying makima despite the fact that
victory was impossible she comes across
two devil Hunters which call on the
Mantis devil one of its arms shooting up
from the ground and slicing her on this
side before she kills the two now
stumbling as a horde of zombies suddenly
rained down upon her we say a young
dirty power running down and stumbling
on a road she looks at her hand
Reminiscing on her belief that all lives
were equally trivial that her life and a
stranger's life was nothing to ever be
said over and that dingy was an
exception to that belief screaming out
that dingy couldn't die in reality a
wounded power bleeding crawls towards an
Alleyway dragging chainsaw man along
with her power slowly moves closer to
the dumpster crawling inside as she
realizes the reason she actually cared
about dingey's life was because he was
her first ever friend a human dingy and
fame power are shown on the dumpster
together the letter happily shouting his
name before hugging him power tells
dingy that she was able to save him with
dingy responding that he was fine and
not in need of saving as he'd already
accomplished all of his dreams going on
to say that his life with power had been
like a dream comparing to the time that
he had with the mafia he tells you again
that he was fine and that nothing good
would ever occur in his life again power
yells at dingy though calling him a
dummy asking him if he truly missed her
so much that he couldn't do anything he
responds that he did and Powell calls
him a fool for not wanting to do so she
goes on to tell him that Devils went to
hell after dying on Earth and that when
they died they would most likely be
enemies if they ever meet again and
despite this he needs to find whatever
she has become and befriend her to turn
it back into the real power so that they
can be buddies again power then forms a
contract with denji giving him the last
of her blood in return for finding the
blood devil again dingy wakes and the
dumpster bolting upright as he shouts
for power well just you know let me come
in here and cutting everything off again
that moment there with power and like
that everything that happens beforehand
with her you know coming back out and
respawning from dingy and then her like
with dingy inside of the dumpster there
is absolutely amazing and I just love
the writing and everything around it the
build up that power has and this story
early on going from this like out of
Brett and she still is a complete
another brat that everyone loves to
being literally dingy sister in a way
and same with my Archie and that aspect
of him becoming like dingy's older
brother that's just absolutely amazing
but anyway enough of me rambling let's
get back to the final battle of this
series or at least of part one at some
point in the future during the daytime
dingy and his hybrid form sits upon a
cross in the graveyard with makima the
katana man Rize Quan Chi the whip hybrid
the spear hybrid the berserk hybrid the
flamethrower hybrid and several dozen
members of Public Safety walking up to
him along a do it path makima walks up
to dinghy as she takes note of his
weaker form before asking if he finally
came to die for her then she gets up
from the cross before asking makima if
there would be any creepy movies in her
vision of a utopian world making him
realize that it was in fact dingy there
and not the true chainsaw man form she
responds that she believed it would be
for the Beast of bad movies were erased
from the world to which dingy says that
he has no choice but to kill her Mucky
massage before telling dingy that
everything about him was not fit for the
chainsaw man four crows are shown flying
up into the sky as dingy spins up his
chainsaws facing makima while she
approaches him along with the hybrids
and many other members of Public Safety
zombies suddenly come up from the graves
around dingy as the zombie devil appears
now also Behind makima these zombies
begin to rush their dingy from all sides
dingy sticks his arms into the ground
shooting his chains down and wrapping
them around a large chunk of Earth
before pushing them up launching several
zombies and a massive rock into the air
behind them pulling the chunk of ground
in front of him and throwing it towards
makima Katana man and the longsword
hybrid leap into the ear both slicing
the chunk of land and cutting it down
into several smaller chunks the two now
vulnerable in the air watches dingy
appears from behind the debris before
cutting them both with his chainsaws
this spear hybrid leaps up from behind
dingy before skewering him with his
chest Reza and the whip hybrid both fly
towards dingy yelling out a Battle Cry
as he spins in the air slicing reset
with one of the chainsaws on his arms
and cutting the Whip and spear hybrids
with the one on his legs dingy and these
slumped bodies of all the Hybrids he
just dunked on then fall to the ground
konji appears from behind denji shooting
him with her arrows the zombies rush in
grabbing him as more and more jump atop
him quickly forming a large pile as he
becomes trapped beneath him makima and
the flamethrower hybrid watch these
zombies where they flamethrower notes
him how dingy was much weaker than he
was before makima says that this was
because the entire world was embracing
chainsaw man and spreading His Image
even going as far as turning him into a
merchandised character and that there
was no longer a need to fear Him still
they've flown through a hybrid Point his
arms towards the pile before shooting it
with his Flames torching it as all of
the zombies begin to burn makima quanchi
and the flamethrower all stand free
moment as they watch the Flames the
flamethrow hybrid yells out in Surprise
as two chains shoot out from the Flaming
Mass each raping around a grave Market
behind him before dingy retracts them
launching himself towards and cutting
the flamethrower hybrid in half as Quan
she blocks him with her arms then she
slices at her and manages to decapitate
Quan Chi but still several more arrows
Pierce home a bloody dingy falls on his
knees then onto his back as makima
stands above him looking down on him
before pointing her finger at her left
palm and saying bang as she shoots a
hole through it she holds her bleeding
Palm above Genji's mouth letting the
blood spilling from it fall into his
mouth she then demands that he wake up
as she wanted to trade blows with him so
that she could kill him personally as a
bunch of Public Safety members float up
behind makima chains appear moving out
from their torsos and connecting them to
her makima pulls on dingey's chest core
creating him before he immediately
decapitates her her head flies off but
due to the chains instead the head of
one of the public safety members
suddenly flies off as makima's head
moves back to her body denji tries to
strike at her again with his left arm
machine as makima Dodges and punches him
in the face knocking him back but dingy
still manages to slice open her chest
with his right arm then again the injury
is transferred to another Public Safety
member as makima once again regenerates
she unleases a flurry of punches
consecutively hitting dingy in the chest
as blood sprays from his mouth though he
still somehow manages to slice her head
off a headless makima kicks dingy in the
chin knocking him back as your head
begins to return to her neck as makima's
head reattaches she punches one of
dinji's arms off destroying it she aims
to punch him again as a chainsaw appears
from dingy's leg kicking her and slicing
her in half makima's torso and lower
half quickly reattach as she turns
around punching a hole straight through
dingy's torso she swings around to the
front grabbing onto a chunk of guts
spilling out of him before punching him
again tearing through his chest as both
of his arms are ripped off oh my God the
actual brutality of that scene that's
when I finally when I finally said it
correctly was mental makima holds onto
dinji's armless corpse from the handle
of his head pulling out pachita with
their right arm as she slowly pulls
pachita out from his body she tells
dingy that dingy was not the chainsaw
man she asks how she could possibly get
him to completely give up on living and
how she could ever possibly get chainsaw
man back denji responds by spitting
blood on her face she continues by
saying that chainsaw man didn't wear
clothes or speak and that he only made a
mess out of everything he did she says
that even with all of dinji's ignorance
he was still chosen as the chainsaw man
and that since he was standing between
makima and him he must die makima fully
breaks pachita from denji's chest blood
spurting from his wounds as he coughs up
blood his head then falls back onto the
ground with makima standing above him
staring down at his motionless corpse
makima walks through the graveyard
stepping through the various bodies of
deceased Public Safety members as she
reaches down and picks up a pack of
cigarettes from the inside of one of the
suits jackets okay I'm not even giving
this fake ass Arc you want to be right
now the time of day she's trying to
smoke and she can't even handle one puff
like what even is this anyway one puff
and he puts out the smoke before picking
up pochita and telling him that it was
now this second time she had ever
defeated him and now he belonged to her
she tells him that they'll be together
forever another eat a lot together sleep
together and live happy together forever
several feet behind makima the goat
himself actually managed to play the
silly witch dingy slowly stands up from
amongst the pile of corpses he slowly
walks over to makima and as she notices
him he takes out a normal chainsaw and
slices her down their freaking chest
Maki mcgastes confused in shocked his
blood spews from your torso falling to
her knees as dingy now stands above her
in a complete role reversal dingy
exclaimed then makima had finally let
her guard down and tells her that he
would now be taking pochita back he
reaches down picking up pochita as he
says that what he just did now was
dangerous and that he had used up all of
the blood power he'd given him from
their contract revealing how he actually
managed to survive without his heart
because technically power was his heart
and like honestly I freaking love that
soppy [__] man katsuki Fujimoto had
different with that one mahima now
bleeding from her mouth and nose asks
how dingy was alive to which dingy
responds that she had actually been
fighting pochita the entire time as
mahima continues to bleed then she tells
her that the chainsaw he had just cut
her with was made out of the blood that
he had got from power and that he was
making it run a muck inside of her
makima says this is hardly enough too to
which dingy cuts her off and says that
he didn't believe he could truly kill
her with such a cheap trick a van pulls
up behind dinghy leading him to happily
exclaim that Master kashibe was there to
pick them up he tells makima he's sorry
before
song coming in and cutting everything
off again because the fight technically
does in here dingy does do some you know
other crazy like mental stuff to
actually defeat makima that I've gone
over in my full chainsaw man video which
if you guys want me to I will re-edit it
in a similar way to how I've done this
fight here and just blur a few panels
and add in some you know bunnies and all
that kind of stuff when [__] just gets a
little bit too hectic for you know like
the YouTube moderation team uh because I
completely understand why they would
want to like restrict this to r18 of
course in some aspects but you know
hopefully they won't for this video here
because I have gone through and try my
best to you know like blur out a few of
those absolutely just mental panels
where it's a bit like virgin on I don't
know if I should be showing this or not
but you know either way I hope you all
have enjoyed this fight it was freaking
like absolutely amazing and if I do end
up like re-editing the entire chainsaw
man story you know like the four hour
long one then I probably will add in a
bunch of the new chapters that have
released because I'm not 100 sure
because I'm not caught up on like a few
chapters behind at the moment but I I
don't think it's finished the first Arc
in part two of chainsaw man yet so it's
not like I can release a full video but
anyway enough of me rambling on about
absolutely random stuff I just you know
I hope you guys all have enjoyed this
video and if you guys want more stuff
just like this from like throughout
chainsaw man like some of the fights
that you find like perhaps your
favorites then let me know down in the
comment section below and I'll be sure
to go of them you know like while the
chainstorm and Anime is releasing but
obviously enough of that if you guys are
new around here then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
really helps out pushing my stuff to a
bunch of new amazing people and again
just thank you for a hundred thousand
Subs it's freaking amazing and you know
thank you to all my patreons who have
been supporting me for like almost a
year now over on there as well you guys
are freaking amazing and I can't thank
you all for it it's just it's completely
and utterly life-changing what has
happened but anyway enough of that now
it's pin your professional degenerate
diavolo and I will see you all enable
bye